Transcriptor: Gisela Giardino
Revisor: Daniel Sainz
Muchas gracias.
Parece que voy primera
porque va por orden de estatura.
Bueno, mi historia
es una historia simple.
No hice grandes cosas,
porque tampoco soy muy grande.
Pero como dice Roberto Benigni
cuando empieza
La Vida es Bella:
Mi historia es una historia simple,
sin embargo,
no es fácil de contar.
Como toda historia tiene dolor,
pero como en toda historia
también hay maravilla,
y felicidad.
Es la historia de esas personas
con las que trabajé
y estuve allá,
mis encuentros con ellos,
es lo que vengo a compartir
hoy con ustedes.
Terminé mi residencia en pediatría
y me incorporé a trabajar
con Médicos sin Fronteras.
Es una organización
médico-humanitaria
que asiste a poblaciones
en situación precaria,
a víctimas de conflictos armados
o de catástrofes naturales,
sin hacer discriminación
por raza, por religión
o por ideología política.
Esta imagen es la primer foto
que un ser humano
sacó de la Tierra,
y representa un poco
esa experiencia que tuve
de empezar a salir de mi mundo
para empezar a mirar
nuestro mundo
y cambiar el punto de vista,
la perspectiva y empezar a tener
una mirada más amplia
y empezar a abrir
un poco más los ojos.
Mis dos misiones fueron en África.
La primera fue en Chad
y la segunda en Níger.
Así que aterricé
a 42ºC de calor,
a otra cultura, a otros idiomas,
a la gente nómada,
la falta de agua,
de rutas, de... de todo.
Y al principio fue duro.
Fue un shock
y siempre que me pedían:
"¿Cómo es África, cómo es?...
contanos tu experiencia"
me salía la frase:
"No, no te lo podés imaginar,
no te lo podés imaginar,
es otro mundo".
Pero, si hay algo que no es,
es otro mundo,
porque como les decía,
justamente, es este mundo.
Mi segunda misión fue en Níger,
Níger tiene todos los números
para ganarse el primer puesto
del país más pobre del mundo.
La esperanza de vida ahí
es de 44 años, o sea que un argentino
puede vivir casi dos vidas en Níger.
Tiene la tasa de natalidad
más alta del mundo,
y el promedio de hijos por mujer
es de casi 8.
El 4% de la superficie de Níger
es cultivable, porque el resto,
tres cuartas partes,
es el Desierto del Sahara.
Así que, no sorprende que Níger tiene
una crisis alimentaria crónica,
que tiene picos de reagudización,
que se conocen
como el período de hambruna.
Ese es el momento en que
se acaba la comida
desde la última cosecha,
hasta que llega la próxima.
Y en ese momento,
la desnutrición hace estragos
en la población,
y afecta especialmente
a los más vulnerables,
que son los chicos,
los menores de 5 años.
Y, bueno, uno sabe
que son más o menos
5 millones los chicos
que mueren cada año en este mundo
por causas relacionadas con la desnutrición,
que, sin embargo,
es una causa tratable y prevenible.
Y son 55 millones de chicos,
casi una Argentina y media,
que sufren de desnutrición
Para mí, todos esos
dejaron de ser números
y empezaron a tener una cara,
unos ojos, una mirada,
un nombre, como Alio,
un apellido, Iacuba Usuf,
ese me costaba mucho, pero...
una mamá, un papá,
un hermanito, una abuela,
y hasta una bisabuela
porque cuando le pedí
si le podía sacar la foto
a esta señora, me sorprendí
al ver a alguien de tanta edad
allá, que no es tan común,
me aclara: "Sí, sí, pero mirá
que yo soy bisabuela, no una abuela".
Así que todo eso,
todo lo que yo había leído
en los libros de medicina:
la diarrea mata y, la neumonía
es la principal causa de muerte
en menores de 5 años...
todo eso se empezó a convertir
en mi realidad de todos los días.
Le vi la cara a la malaria,
la conocí bien de cerca,
y, en medio de vivir esa realidad,
y que eso se convierta
en algo del día a día,
palpable,
eso dejó de ser un número,
y me tocó.
Llegó un momento en que
uno pierde un poco las fuerzas
y sentí que todo lo que hacía
no tenía mucho sentido.
Yo sentía que tratábamos
a uno, uno, uno,
pero que afuera eran millones.
En ese momento
me acordé de un cuento,
que dice que hay un señor
que después de una tormenta
sale a caminar por la playa
y encuentra muchísimas,
miles y miles de estrellas de mar,
que después de la tormenta
habían quedado sobre la arena.
Y a lo lejos ve a otro que,
iba tirándolas al mar.
Entonces se acerca, un poco irónico
y un poco con lástima,
al pobre tipo y le dice:
"¿Para qué te tomás el trabajo?
En cuatro horas
van a estar todas muertas".
Y el señor agarra una y le dice:
"Esta no".
Y, volví a empezar y a decir:
"Este chiquito, no".
¿Cómo abordamos el tema
entonces de la desnutrición?
¿Qué hacíamos frente a esto?
Básicamente teníamos
un programa ambulatorio
y otro para internar a los chicos.
En el programa ambulatorio,
las mamás traen a sus chicos,
a veces caminan 15 o 20 km
bajo pleno rayo de sol,
y en Níger les puedo asegurar
que 45 grados
es la temperatura promedio,
para traer a sus chicos a la consulta.
Ahí nosotros los registramos,
los medimos, los pesamos,
y, también hacemos
el perímetro braquial,
se toman todas las medidas,
también jugamos -- los que no se asustan
jugamos con ellos.
Yo era de otro planeta para ellos,
porque, al tener la piel blanca,
ser petisa y colorada,
venía de Marte, más o menos.
Muchos se acercaban y hacían así,
a ver si abajo estaba el negro...
era la primera vez
que veían a alguien...
Así que, bueno, estábamos con ellos,
se hacía la consulta médica también,
y una vez que habíamos hecho
todos los tratamientos,
se les entrega estos
alimentos terapéuticos de rápido uso,
que revolucionaron
el tratamiento de la desnutrición.
Estos alimentos, parece una pavada,
pero no necesitan refrigeración,
ni agua para su preparación.
Y eso, en países como
los de África por ejemplo,
donde no hay heladera
y no hay agua potable,
permitió llegar a millones de chicos,
para tratar la desnutrición
de forma ambulatoria
que antes era muy difícil.
Porque si no implicaba una internación
y las madres no podían
dejar a los otros hijos
para traer al hospital a uno o a dos.
Así que esto fue una maravilla,
y es una maravilla hoy en día.
Los chicos que,
por su estado tan avanzado
no podían,
no tenían fuerzas para comer,
o, los chicos con alguna
patología médica asociada,
entonces para ellos teníamos
un centro de recuperación
nutricional intensivo,
que es un hospital
para chicos desnutridos agudos severos,
donde llegamos a tener
en la época de mayor actividad,
este período de hambruna,
hasta casi 400 pacientes internados.
El trabajo era posible
gracias al trabajo en equipo,
y ésa es una de las experiencias
más ricas que uno hace allá,
me parece,
que es trabajar codo a codo,
con gente de ahí y con gente
de otras partes de mundo
por un objetivo en común.
Ahí no hay fronteras,
no importa de dónde uno viene,
qué piensa, qué religión tiene,
qué color de la piel tiene,
estamos todos para lo mismo.
Atendíamos a casi 400 chicos,
por día, era el promedio de internación.
Y, éste es, por ejemplo, un caso:
Senagu había venido con
una desnutrición severa
y una neumonía.
Hicimos el tratamiento,
y ésta es Senagu
antes de irse a su casa
para seguir el tratamiento ambulatorio.
A veces teníamos éxitos,
y a veces fracasos.
Había que seguir.
Pero eran, sobretodo,
las madres y sus chicos
los que luchaban hasta el final.
Esto me lo enseñó Furera y su mamá.
Furera llegó al programa, también,
como cualquier otro de los chicos.
Empezamos el tratamiento
nutricional y médico
y empezó a mejorar el peso
hasta que el peso empezó a estancarse
y nos dimos cuenta que Furera tenía
un tuberculosis avanzada.
Y, a pesar de que habíamos
instaurado el tratamiento,
Furera empezó a empeorar, a empeorar
y eran muchas las veces que me iba del hospital
y no sabía si al día siguiente
la iba a encontrar de vuelta a Furera.
Sin embargo, ella tiene una valentía
y una lucha impresionante,
y la vi a Furera respirar,
y luchar por la vida, hasta el final.
Me conmovió y conmovía a muchos,
hicimos todo lo que había
a nuestro alcance.
Esta es la última foto
que tengo de Furera porque
terminó mi misión y volví a Argentina.
Pero fueron las madres y sus hijos,
los que me enseñaron
que vale la pena la lucha,
lucharla hasta el final.
Que cada estrella de mar
que vuelve al mar, vale la pena.
Creo que nosotros no tenemos
la solución
para los problemas del mundo
en nuestras manos,
pero frente a los problemas de mundo,
tenemos nuestras manos.
Hay que dejar de hablar, quizás,
de un primer mundo, un tercer mundo,
porque en esa línea podemos hablar
de un cuarto, un quinto, un sexto,
y es solamente un mundo.
Este mundo en el que vivimos todos.
Y creo que, si cada uno aporta
su granito de arena,
se puede hacer algo al respecto.
Cada uno puede hacer,
desde lo que cada uno es, tiene y puede.
Pero creo que ese granito de arena,
puede hacer que entre todos
hagamos un mundo mejor,
y más amable para todos.
En lo que les conté,
no hay súper héroes.
Yo, cuando volví, no me animé
a comunicarme con la gente de allá
para saber cómo le había ido a Furera,
cómo había seguido.
No tenía el valor de saber que otro más
se nos había escapado de las manos.
Dos meses más tarde de haber vuelto,
me contacta mi amiga Michelle,
que era otra pediatra
que estaba trabajando conmigo,
y me manda un mail,
para mandarme esta foto,
que es la foto de Furera
antes de irse de alta.
Así que Furera fue mi estrella de mar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)